[Music]
here I just go ahead I I'm just pairing
his arms and blocking but eventually
he's going to get
me as he pushes you have to tilt you see
how I
tilt it's not enough to just push and
stop him eventually he gets around it
because he has his bow so on the first
Swan there just enough to just on that
thumb right there you feel it okay so he
has to go around it and that's when he
opens up so let's look at what happens
so here here's the little this enough
tilt and he could feel that that's going
to assist it so when he went around it
look that was Yin go back
back right there he goes That's Yin
that's what I follow in but it's not
that I'm pushing on it till he goes
around it and then I just keep
working so again on contact tilt there's
the Tilt don't ask for more okay cuz he
he's he's pulling back do you feel how
you're he's trying to get his bows back
that's all I wanted then look at his
spine you see how he's tilted backward
there's the
[Music]
C yeah tilt it's enough so you feel it
again you feel it again so he he wants
to come back so I let him come back and
then we're in the same boat over here
but at that angle over there you see how
he y to get off of it I follow it in
and so again on contact there's the
tilts don't ask for more cuz he's going
to counter it and he went back
again not
here catch so always
tilt he goes
around he goes
around and opens it
up okay let's try it
again all right so tactically for your
Kon waza this is just the essence of it
that the guy's going to have some young
energy and you're going to take it into
a spinal tilt he's going to react to it
and then you keep uh reconciling yin and
yang as it's going but those two
components he's going to give yangong so
I'm going to do some sort of Yin
manifestation and in that Yin
manifestation I'm going to tilt him he's
in this case because it's not prescribed
he do things okay uh but those things
then will keep taking him further and
further off balance okay so we have to
ask why all right so he's going to make
contact there's his young energy so I
come around and you have this Yin yield
so let's look at this one go back he
comes there's your Yin
yield and he had that one too and this
one just went out the the two went this
way you see there's my tilt okay but I
didn't just get out of the way it's not
going to tilt him and that's where the
internal comes in so do you feel that
pull right he go it's a pull and then
when he goes off of when he's trying to
get out of it pay pay
attention it get it's getting more do
you feel it it's getting more friction
even as you're moving okay and then that
makes you want
makes you pull more it increases more
okay so I can't just try to tilt him I
have to yield and stick I don't have
much here can you see that but you can't
come forward on that arm do you see that
and as you come forward you'll feel it
increasing the adhesion and now I can do
stuff with it you see you feel that okay
but so I don't do anything it's just
checking you here but this hand is
adhering and so you're going to do
whatever right and now this hand
increase did you feel it increase okay
and so then I can do
my again reach tilt but it's there's I'm
going to show you keep keep that hand
there I'm going to show you that there's
a friction in
there and the same thing over here
there's a friction you feel it okay I'm
not
just doing that in friction he counter
by clutching his stomach so I wait I'm
not pushing on him I just wait he'll do
something but it's
adhering takes him into the next
one it's not that he goes back in and
then I'm just pushing I know I said that
last time but as he goes
back I
Pro so it's why why do I project cuz
when he feels that he goes back what do
you do he pushes his so we'll do that
again he goes back I follow he pushes
into me and that's what I
[Music]
project it's not that I'm going here he
goes back and then I just
push just like it's not that I'm going
out of the way I'm in
hearing you went
back okay but he pushed at the last
second and give me that energy what I'm
seeing you guys do is you come to the
elbows and you kind of just push here
and then he comes around and you're like
pushing on the elbows and pushing on the
elbows no and
here he does
[Music]
something
okay I got get the Tilt with the Tilt
has to be done yes through Yin
but Yin external but internal as
adhesion I okay
try so in your
keyone the Tactical spectrum is that
you're grappling at arms length
Okay uh so it's a different Tal Spectrum
than like your your other gr Point your
double legs
and uh your various trips and all that
kind of stuff you're out you're out here
you're out here so one thing I don't
think you've ever noticed is that as he
goes I don't go here I'm not on the
elbow you see if you I think if you're
on the elbow range you're in a different
tactical spectum Okay so so pay
attention to that and I would also note
that if I have his
elbows and his arms are still here like
you I've seen you guys do that a lot
that's entirely different from look
where his hands are and then some of the
ones that I was doing his hands are back
here that's entirely different you and
my arms extended but his arms are
towards me you see this is easy peasy
push right
it's
easy different
here he moves he just goes further back
okay note that another difference
is if you as you're watching me not only
am I never on the
elbows I'm down at this grappling range
go ahead is that my arm
arms uh don't
hyperextend and they don't really go too
compact either so when he pushes
whatever I won't do that unless I'm I'm
just playing on what I'm doing okay I
kind of keep my
arms with that same katatori elbow Bend
so he's
[Music]
going
not
going you see all that okay so I
I extended I would like for you to feel
where that I is taking into those Tils I
want you to bring awareness to
that
and you feel it every time you
see it's not that you just push and I
get up all way you push and
I
stick
[Music]
s
okay can you feel that get use that to
till as opposed to the push
arm and just getting out of the way
okay so what I'm answering here is you
know how do I how do I stop pull pushing
stopping him stopping him or how do I
stop pull stop pulling on you okay what
I'm saying is we'll just do a single
push there's no push that you can't take
into either of these kazushi angles the
Y kazushi angles so he I can take him
this way and I can take him that
way and likewise there's no Yin he's
going back and there's no Yin that I
can't take into the Y kazushi angles I
take him that way he goes back I take
them that way you see so if that's the
case then I don't want he goes he's
trying to hit my chest there's no reason
why I try to stop him right now he's you
see you're pushing on my elbow do you
see that you feel that okay so instead I
let him push and I take it into the
angle and he doesn't like the angle so
he's going back and I take it into the
yin kazushi anle those are the four
corners okay so there's no there's if
you pay attention I don't ever stop him
there's the front one and you know what
I'm going to do is he goes back and
there it is right
there so that's all your playing from
another point of
view every time he goes back take it
into the corner time he goes forward
take it into the corner and he he can
he's only going to do one of those two
things in this game because for
prescription he's trying to hit my chest
and once I stick to him he has to try to
get off of it so go he's here he can't
get off of it going
forward he can't get off it going
forward
so he has to go backwards when he goes
backwards that's when I take the into
the Y Kazi
angles in this case then there's no
reason to stop him to stop him to stop
him okay it's not a matter of going I'm
not ready there's no ready to be it's
happening you're just it is what it is
okay
[Music]
for
you
[Music]
so
let if he's pushing take them take him
okay when he goes to get off stick
follow take them take them okay let's
try it again for a little
bit so we are okay
pay pay
attention
Okay you you feel what you feel you're
never going to fall here you do you
understand that okay but who is your
Center yours think about it okay this is
kazushi the center part not the not the
Tilt part I know that I said as you push
and I take it but it's the that's the
kazushi this go ahead this is not the
C okay so even here you're perfectly
upright you see but same thing if you if
you feel that okay so that that's in
your centry so as you try to move move
as slowly as you can try and
encounter you look at your Center moving
you see keep keep going as slow as you
can
feel what you
feel do you
see just something because it's not ever
what it looks
like and I think as you're
training you after a while you have to
not believe what you see okay
after a while do you understand like at
a certain point your eyes are now
working against
you